a quick phone call to a colleague nearby
everyone in the neighborhood is waiting
for an electricity worker to arrive with
a flick of a switch they turn off
electricity in one neighborhood and
power up somewhere else
Gaza is getting very little electricity
from the Israeli grid my colleague he
was waiting for call from someone of the
eastern line to switch on the
electricity what happened is he just
shut off the connection from the western
side because this neighborhood's turn is
over though just a few streets away my
Sultan is hurrying to fill the washing
machine her neighborhood has electricity
again but only for precious three hours
a day all of that in the middle of the
summer
when the electricity buys I start
washing my laundry and do anything else
I need energy for I have to do it as
well very quickly for our army look even
the makeshift battery system which
supplies a little light during a
blackout needs to be charged nothing is
working
refrigerators water pumps elevators
last week the two million inhabitants of
Gaza had to make do with less than three
hours per day the situation is going
from bad to worse our self-proclaimed
leaders in Gaza and the West Bank would
not just consider their own interest but
finally take the wishes of the people
into account then something might change
the momentum see se Shui with a mobile
necessary site up sister here Gaza has
been located by Israel and Egypt for
more than a decade in April Garza's only
power plant had to be shut down because
of a lack of fuel
since then Gaza has dependent on energy
from Egypt and Israel but last week
Israel reduced its own electricity
supply at the request of Palestinian
President Mahmoud Abbas he no longer
wants to pay the power bill for the Gaza
Strip which is controlled by his rival
Hamas the sole alternative is for mass
to respond to the initiative of the
President
by handing over the border crossings
reverting from its COO and by handing
over all government institutions to the
government of national consensus Hamas
is under further pressure because Qatar
one of its main sponsors is having
problems of its own since 2014 the Gulf
state had been financing streets
hospitals and even fuel clear that the
main cause of this impasse is the
Israeli occupation in cooperation with
President Abbas people should protest
against those behind the blockade we are
telling our people that they have to
tolerate more of this reality on Gaza
coastline one can smell the fallout of
the crisis long before one sees it this
is where the sewage from millions of
gallons is flushed into the
Mediterranean Sea the dirty water then
flows north towards Israel we're talking
about 100 thousand cubic meters of
sewage water that reaches the beach
it's either only partially treated or
not at all and while Egypt recently
delivered a small amount of fuel to the
Gaza Strip that shipment was just a drop
in the ocean in an ever worsening crisis